[Music]
hey everybody Joel nuclear and I'm
joined by Matt Holland from Larian
studios
oh thanks for having me yet yeah how was
your flight uh really good slunk from
Dublin but I was made here one piece was
happy to have you here we're taking a
look at divinity original sin two
definitive edition why don't you guys
call it a definitive edition you know
the number of times I've tripped over
and made that exactly state you think we
may as well but the guys in publishing
it insisted on definitive it yeah and it
might cause some confusion all right so
we're looking at the game on PlayStation
4 here and we're gonna go through some
of the changes because it sounds like
you guys have actually added a lot to
this game yes it's not just a port we're
not just bringing it to Xbox one and ps4
we've also done a huge overhauls of the
game as a whole to really give you guys
the best definitive edition of the game
and I mean we're just gonna let's jump
into character ation here look I should
kind of show you guys for the people who
aren't as familiar with divinity you
know what we're all about and some of
the things you can do in creating your
character right it's a game tyrion the
character creator and yeah while we just
run through what you can do with this
yeah so I mean as a little intro to the
world of divinity we we in the world
divinity are sorcerers and now see it's
not a very good time for sorcerers in
divinity see we're getting blamed for
all the void woken these big monsters
coming into the world so they've been
rounding us all up and they've been
throwing us into the penal colony of
Fort joy now obviously with any RPG you
always start off with creating who you
are so we're gonna create our sorcerer
and now a really cool thing about
divinity and click we're the only RPG
who does this is that we allow the full
game to be played in coop and not just
go up online but couch co-op
split-screen yes I had a fantastic time
playing the game last year
online co-op with my friends and I'm
really excited that this game has split
screen with the console so I'm hoping to
play it with my girlfriend this time oh
yeah here we go see and now the screen
splits in half and it's so easy yeah and
we can just create our characters of
real time and run through the entire
game if from start to finish off is a
lot of fun now the most important part
are for for me I think my favorite part
of character creation isn't just
choosing your skills and you know what
your character do what they look like
but also their background now you tend
play a custom character without a
background but I think probably my
favorite part is choosing a character
with an orange and now an origin is
actually a character this exists inside
of the world so for example I'm sitting
on here with the red prints yes right
and I can kind of look at its origin
info here but I also hear his story he
can tell it to me like this
[Music]
famed of course for my unique red skin
and unparalleled skills as a general of
the House of War I the red prince was
raised within the vast palaces of the
fabled Forbidden City I was destined to
become the next Emperor
but my ambitions suffered a bit of a
setback when I fell from grace took a
vaulting with demons
[Applause]
now I'm exiled and hunted by assassins
that I assure you I remain undaunted and
is determined as ever to claim my
rightful throne
so that's actually just one of our six
origin characterized and even if you
don't choose an origin character in the
game you're just gonna see them pop up
in the actual game world because like I
said before they exist inside of the
world you can actually recruit every
single one of these origins as a
companion your party if you don't choose
them in character creation yeah it's
funny the red prints in fact ended up
the beginning he was probably my least
favorite party member mhm
uh he actually became one of my
favorites but oh yeah we have a lot of
people say that because it's a bit rough
around the edges let's start but yeah I
think he grows on a lot of people but
yeah I think he's one of my he's one of
my favorites personally I think my
favorite origin is probably Seville I
like me I like Joe as well
the of assassin I picked Llosa when I
first played oh right on another another
one of the fan figure I really I really
liked her sort of unique dynamic with
with her voice in her head I thought
that is really cool
and after we choose our origin our
backstory we also get to choose things
like our build precinct now we do have a
what we call a classless system in
divinity so you can build up your
character in any way you like
so the preset is just there it's just
kind of like you know a basic build but
you can go over and adjust everything
you want to make your character as
custom as you like yes
but you know what I think I'm gonna take
a look at these and after we kind of do
some of the stats we go into what we
call the tag system now the tag system
is really cool this is what lets us
roleplay inside of the world of divinity
see your tags are actually pay huge role
in the game in that they allow you to
make specific dialogue choices only
available to characters those tags so
for example the red prince you can see
has the red Prince tag so obviously he's
the only one who's gonna be able to get
those tag options those dialogue options
and it's not just what you can do it's
also how the world perceives you so if a
group of assassins comes over and sees
the red prince and they know they're
trying to find the red principle they're
obviously gonna try to kill him but if
they talk to say Llosa or one of the
other characters they might just wander
off so not only is their game inside of
you moving as a party there's also game
inside of who do you choose to interact
with the world with on a character for
character basis
but you know what guys I think this
gives you a pretty good idea about
what's going on inside the game so why
don't we just jump right in so we're
good so let's jump in to the actual game
itself yes and here we are inside of
Fort joy alright now we've kind of
jumped ahead a little bit we've uh we
skipped over the tutorial area and we're
we're kind of now into the mean of the
game yes so like I said before the the
Magisters taking up all the sorcerer's
including us and throwing us into the
penal colony here and we kind of got to
find a way okay I don't know about you I
rather not stay inside of a penal colony
no definitely not
all right do you have a specific thing
you want to do oh wow look at it split
screen yeah there you go so that's one
of the cool things about the game is
when we're close together so you're
playing the Red Prince and I'm playing
with my own guys when close the screen
will come together oh and when we go out
on our own separate ways in the world
the game yeah oh that's great
so even if I'm in combat you can be off
trading with the merchants or
interacting with an animal whatever you
wanted tell that's fantastic so like I
said we go we got to kind of find a way
out of this place and for me I'm kind of
looking at these brutes over here that
they're trying to shake down myself for
money and I want to see how I want to
interact with this right so I'm gonna
click on them and see what happens
inside of this situation okay and even
though I'm far away it lets me hearing
on well see you very different guy
yeah I'm that just happens at the same
time so we can actually even though we
both want to escape we don't have to
escape the same way so for example you
can you can find a way out yourself
where it's I'm trying to you know
resolve this issue with these brutes
shaking down this elf you can find your
way out with Gowen here oh I remember
this guy yeah
in the elf rolls up his sleeves
revealing well-muscled so for me in my
situation here I'm seeing these brutes
trying to take the the money in the food
from this elf here and this is where my
choices in the game are really gonna
count for something I am no see you this
situation we play out in a bunch of
different ways
now do I decide to help out the elf and
you know fight the brutes take them on
maybe I try to help out the brutes
instead and try to get some money off
this elf or you know maybe I try to
resolve this peacefully instead and you
know try not to cause any war here
there's a lot of guards Mike Mike yeah
might not work out the best first let's
uh let's just try to do the peaceful
thing and resolve this peacefully now
the cool thing about this is because I
chose to resolve this peacefully
and help them out this character right
here Ethan Ben next is actually going to
be a lot more friendly to me and just so
happens that Ethan is one of our six
origin characters yes so like we said
before they can be your critical Pat
companions and what do you say why don't
we bring them on board let's do it we
need winning one where a person in our
party so let's go alright fantastic
we're gonna shake his hand a bit go
through his dialogue here and now if N
is a a former lone wolf he used to be a
mercenary and we actually find out later
on down the line that he used to work
with who will eventually become one of
our enemies inside of the game just go
so he has a lot of really interesting
opinions and outlook around the game
that obviously only he's gonna get
because he has the if intact so he's
gonna have those unique interactions
yeah even though I played through this
game last year on the PC I mean I still
feel like I want to sync another you
know eighty hours into it because you
don't get ahead bring everyone with you
and we party so I'm
potential like cool stories like I
actually didn't bring your family with
me truth and I I kind of feel like I
missed out and I'm like I want to play
it again this time I want to bring it on
well that's a really cool thing too and
then another big push that we deal with
the definitive edition is we've really
gone through and added a lot more
options for those characters especially
for beast who a lot of people felt like
that just wasn't enough content for him
specifically we've gone through
especially in the later parts of the
game and given him a lot more stuff to
do a lot more unique interactions with
that area oh that's great before we hit
the road survival and now another one of
those things that you know really missed
me with some RPGs maybe I like the
characters but they don't fit the right
roles in my RPG party you know well I
really like this guy but I need a mage
and he's a fighter right so one of the
things we can do is say if any much I
would like you to be a battle mage or a
fighter or whatever whatever composite
we need you're never restricted to just
the personality you can always choose
when you first recruit them to be
whatever you want them to me yeah I love
that about this there's a yeah like you
said it free it kind of frees you up to
really focus on the story and also have
like the right party composition with
those characters because yeah I've
definitely played games before where I
was like ah I love this character but I
can't put them in my party like so then
I'll have like two healers or whatever
and it just doesn't fit so that's I I
think that's so cool that you guys did
that and it's um it's also nice because
because of the classes system if you do
pick something but you'd rather you know
your healer be a Pyromancer or shooting
fireballs people you could still build
them up throughout the rest of the game
you're never locked into one specific
class right and now it looks like I have
three guys and you only have the one so
I'm actually going to give you a guy how
do you think you think Thane or if in
who-who do you want I'll take Fame
alright I think that's a good choice
there he's one of my favorites too
alright sweet Oh what am i doing not
there we go there we go awesome I think
I need to know this way all right you
just uh you cause he's like disconnected
for you right now yeah so if you just
hold the right or sorry left trigger
mm-hmm and you just press the triangle
button there we go thank you thank you
awesome and now we're off yeah men you
seem all new as well yeah it's it's
similar to the ones we used for the
first dose thanks for that enhanced
edition but we've really gone through
and we've upgraded a lot so you've
already seen like the new improved UI
systems we have you're already looking
at it right there yeah that looks like
you got it seems like new visual flares
to it does that stop translate to the PC
version as well are there changes to the
UI yeah absolutely everything has been
gone over with a fine-tooth comb
especially things like the journal so if
you look at the journal it's actually
going to have a it's a lot more
comprehensive it's gonna not only tell
you what you've learned but give you a
better general idea of where you need to
go and what you need to do it now this
is kind of a hard thing for us but we
didn't want to be too hand-holding right
you know we still want to have that
authentic RPG experience we don't want
to tell you exactly where to go what do
we want you to be able to find your own
way and let you role play the way you
want to do it ya know that's something I
really liked about the journal and the
game was that it would it wasn't there
to exactly like tell you go to this way
point and click on this and that's how
you beat the class because you know
these quests are very open-ended but
it's nice that yeah it seems like you
guys are maybe trying to give a little
bit of hints for those who cuz there are
definitely times where I'm like I've I
have no idea what to do do I continue
this quest well that's the thing is well
right like we also want some people who
aren't playing hardcore people who only
have a you know four or five hours a
week or even less to come back and go
jump back in the game and still have a
rough good idea
what they're doing and that and that's
that's really a big push for the journal
just to make it clearer for people what
they need to do and what they and where
they need to go right so let's keeps
going we kind of come across this guy
here yeah this guy is pretty interesting
I remember
he's uh he's kind of eating all the dead
bodies so uh why don't we go talk to him
I don't you go click on that guy yeah
I'll talk to him I'll be the one I'm
gonna join in see even though we're
playing separately I can still join it
in your conversation by listening I love
now I get to see what's going on with
you and your decision host was quite
lost yeah that was a really fun thing
playing co-op with friends would be
they're the ones making the decision and
you could like you know we're talking
over the voice Chad you can tell him
like do this to do that but like they're
the ones who makes the decision and if
they're like well no I think my
character would do this and I was like
no it feels like like a D&D game in that
sense well that's what we're ultimately
striving for it Larry is to make a pen
and paper experience and so if you want
to you know do what you think your
character you do if you're willing if
you want to play the red prince you can
you can role play the red prince if you
want to do what you want to do as a
person you can do that as well it's all
up to you now so I guess it's what is it
my turn first yep it looks like it is
alright so this is our first little
combat here in the game now if you're
new to divinity you're gonna notice that
the games kind of changed now we've gone
to turn base mode so while you're
attracting the world you are in real
time but once we get to combat then the
game stops and if you get to interact
inside of your own turn see now my turns
done and now it's the enemy's turn and
he's a pretty powerful enemy
you need to get away from him yeah next
it's your turn okay so do I need to kill
anyone okay I'm okay
all right our yellow closer
so you see that did a little bit of
damage to him but you saw that a
decaying touch was actually blocked now
we have not only on top of your regular
health bar we have two other bars that
are relevant to your stats of your
physical armor and your magical armor
that's the gray and the blue right
actively so I can still damage a
character who's who has those armors up
but any ailments or status effects are
not going to affect them if they still
have that kind of armour on them so for
example if I tried to if you fight it
knock him down here because he still had
some armor up you do the damage but you
don't knock it down you just yep let's
see here I think you
[Music]
get fire but he's got all this magic
armor
now fortify might be nice because he he
does a lot of physical damage so we
wanna make sure all right yeah let's
fortify myself all right my turn so I'm
gonna to inspire you guys do you summon
courage here buff up the group and oh I
can't move because he he crippled me
with his attack okay I'm gonna try to
use this knock down arrow hope it's
gonna be enough to punch through his
armor just not enough I don't know we're
we're in dire straits here buddy
all right
Oh No are we on fire
no no not yet if you know divinity you
know how fast things just off fire fire
fire
catches ya everywhere it's ridiculous
now luckily his physical armor is gone
now
let's see well I could do
no needs healing yet so I'm like you
healthier I think he just healed them a
little bit did I oh no that's alright I
think I think we still got this because
he like a no no he's on the dead though
is he I think it's the skill he died it
sucks up all the blood around him he'll
say no I don't even think of that that's
alright we're just making him
overconfident here yeah exactly this is
the fake outz
lagging we got here I'm just gonna hit
that's the thing like getting into this
game you have to remember all these
little like oh yeah like well you know
they're Undead so don't u know don't u
s-- poison because that'll heal them and
stuff like that there's a lot of systems
to this game and it's it's really fun
trying to like figure out how they all
interact with each other hey and that's
a big thing is trying to design a game
inside of so many systems right because
every every action that you do every
time you try to design one of these
situations you have to take into account
all the different ways a player can
interact with these themselves so you
know if you're trying to save man PC
from you know a cell it's not just you
being able to find the key and unlock
the key you have things like a teleport
spell so you can teleport them out of
the Sun right so you always going to be
extra aware of the other ways players
can cheat the system
get a ring armor this brings pretty good
cuz it gives you free restoration that's
pretty good yeah especially for early in
the game you really want those nice
heels now see I just found the secret
here because my character has really
high wits I was able to spot this dirt
pile okay now we can actually dig away
here let's see what we find
would you look at that it's a little
hatch do you think we go in good let's
do it maybe maybe even find some way out
I remember there being so many different
ways to go out like I we hit a point
when we were playing where we found a
way out of for joy and then we're like
well I did feel like we haven't explored
everything let's go back and like check
and then we found like three more ways
to get out and we're like okay which one
should we take now I love the amount of
options this game presents well you know
the funny thing about that is and we we
definitely designed this whole area
about trying to find give the player his
chance to find his own way out but the
funny thing is once we launched on early
access we actually found players who are
finding unintended ways out oh really
just just ways that we didn't even see
but because of the systemics we talked
about there are always ways to kind of
cheat system just a little bit and
obviously we're not gonna patch that we
want to play we want the players yes we
want you to Joe as an example labor fuel
using teleport or yeah there are a lot
of ones with teleport where they they
would find a little just a little patch
of area where they could teleport or
guide - and then they use that as a way
out I remember you can talk to the slug
if we had a pet pal but I don't think
anyone are pretty let's see maybe does a
fan have it I wants me
Oh No have it that's too bad
bummer
that's alright though so now coming up
here
is another little situation that gives
us a lot of opportunity to display how
we want to interact with it okay the
fire is flying creature looms it is the
fire singing gurgle hmm
so like you said before we don't have
pet pal now if we did a pet Pelt it's
just a skill allows you to talk to any
animal in the game or discuss a fire
slug highly useful very useful but
unfortunately we did not now we do not
take [ __ ] but that's alright I don't
think she's gonna be too happy with us
here and we get into a bit of a fight
now I think we're a bit under leveled
for this fight oh but maybe we can paint
right we can try our fast rising up in
here
alright well I got water balloon and
someone from the Moscow so we start with
yeah
also that'll get fires like wet Jason
will help out and that's not a cool
thing we have in the game that new
people to the series will notice is that
our services that you find in the game
are completely systemic so what happens
if you have a fire service in the ground
and you put water on it well it turns
into steam and doses the fire what
happens if you put electricity onto that
water service you just made well it was
left to fight water and then when you
walk in that you get stunned and you can
keep on going through these this loop
infinitely you can keep on interacting
with those surfaces and it gets really
interesting when later on in the game
you come across skills like curse and
bless
so we have another stomach in the game
that allows you to make cursed and
blessed variants of all those services
so you have so many different options so
many different ways to interact with the
environment it's not just about who does
the most damage in combat it's about who
uses the environment to the most effect
I love going on
find people who would mention all these
crazy things if that was like so cool of
like combinations of I gotta you know
they survived this spell in this spell I
remember somebody mentioned to me how it
when you're in a dungeon it was a torch
if you shoot an arrow through it it
would be laid on fire and I was like why
like you can do that like there's just
all these little things that you could
do that was crazy yeah I I would like I
would do a lot that's the thing about
this game even though we're underleveled
we're still able to pose a pretty big
threat in fact we might even be able to
pull this one out I think we're doing
all right we're doing all right
and the thing is even if we don't finish
this one out we're still able to reload
or save and try a new method yeah
so that that's another cool thing where
whenever it locked into our position
even if it didn't work out with the
slugs here maybe we could even go back
into for joy and like you said before
you and your your friends find different
options different options you know to
find different ways because we always
have the people who love you know the
completionists this is I think a very
satisfying game for the completionist as
well because there's so many different
options so many different ways to
complete a goal and you're just never
gonna see everything inside of one
playthrough yeah absolutely because we
never did this fight we we had Pet Pals
so we're actually able to talk to the
slugs and
combat great and now you finally get to
see the other side of it exactly what
this would happen to all the slugs and
the fire hellscape that they create oh
so much all right what do we got here
you know I'm sure brush past this guy
here with our little princess there who
I am not doing very well my my health is
oh now all right well we got got a
healing potion here okay it's in that
out there
right back to me here
Oh and he is stuck in smoke there which
means I can't see them inside that smoke
cloud say it's another like I said
before all the services are bound by
systemics science eventually fire is
going to burn out and that turns into
smoke
[Applause]
and just give us guys buff again
[Music]
you know my I think my favorite little
trick I learned was is uh you can take
nails and you could combine them with
your shoes and so you could walk on ice
and you wouldn't slip I thought that was
so clever hey did you guys like it did
you guys just like brainstorm like all
the like different like crazy like well
what if people want to combine this with
this and like how would that affect like
well it comes a lot more natural than
that it's not we don't just take an
asset like nails and say what can we do
with the nails we we kind of play the
game and we say oh wouldn't it be cool
while in the middle of play session
we'll come up with these crazy ideas
that come out of nowhere and then
implement it somebody implements it and
then it's just a thing from then until
the end of time all right likes to live
I think that one's dead okay but there
is one man you there thinking this
no it's getting up close to my Ranger
hear us alright we got the right Prince
to save the day I'm really impressed how
easy it is to just play this co-op on
one screen yeah I mean the cool thing is
that it's completely dropped and drop
out so it's not like if you started a
game of play session without me like you
saw just here this wasn't a game that we
started from character creation right
you just jumped in and we're able to
play on the same save and you can eat
just needs a jump out and come back 20
hours of gameplay later and yeah I might
have to explain a few things
yeah good all right if anyone who's
watching this video hasn't played the
game but didn't play it co-op I highly
recommend giving coopera tracts I really
think that's where this game shines I
had such a good time playing with
friends it was probably one of my it was
one of my favorite experiences of last
year well that's great to hear
and another thing if you do like the
co-op side of thing or maybe a little
bit of the PvP side we've actually gone
back and revamped our entire arena mode
Oh which was which was a at release for
the PC a little bit bare bones but we've
gone through and we've actually updated
it so that you can be only need one
controller now to play locally we have a
hot seat mode oh okay we've gone through
and add a much cooler character
selection scene so you can now choose
from a variety of characters across the
divinity universe not just through
dusty'll but through other games in the
divinity series oh that's me and yeah
we've even added a few little cool
quirks inside of there a few different
game modes that you can try out to see
who's the arena master who's the best
among you and your friends oh we lost
the red prince
I don't know man this is looking pretty
dire straits here yeah said fire it was
the first thing we did was really
someone get a rain spell is everything
catches on fire in this game
still can't see him yeah there's trying
dude
now what love these guys
level three yeah I think this is
probably yeah happens inside of the game
that happens a lot for sure you got you
got to be prepared to trial and error
but I would enjoy that because we would
mean my friends you know you're talking
are your strategies and you're thinking
well can't we'll try this and that but
then when you fail it becomes his
learning experience that well that
didn't work
play it's like oh no I have an idea this
time all you know my brain juror will
kind of like sneak in and maybe like go
up on top and I plan an attack and I'll
move this barrel over here so that you
can shoot it and stuff like that like
die I love that about this game and
that's another really fun thing about it
is that you there's always ways to
adjust your strategy so it we weren't
test completely outmatched even though
we were a lower level they don't think
we would be for example you know if I
switch my characters and you know maybe
I I sneak
[Music]
maybe we can even get behind them and
avoid the situation entirely
oh I think when this flux spot view but
yeah that's all right as long as wait oh
is that all so here
now move up these vines very cynically
as a rock alone oh no one suspects it's
so good they can
no way out there oh yeah it's alright
it's only the Queen who's gonna address
this so she's the only one that's got
the waiter and the cool thing is that
there's so many ways to play the game
that even if right now we aren't quite
strong enough for a fight we can always
do some quests and come back later
once we're stronger and show those slugs
who's boss
yeah
do we want to there's a really fun quest
where it's help wearing crocodiles do we
want to try that one oh we can try that
absolutely yes let's look let's go back
to for joy and thankfully we should have
save any weight points
oh yeah wait so just get be right back
in there yeah so we can actually wait
for it to Fort J Square oh that's so
fast
and now we're back at it so I think you
already talked to Gowen yeah I got the
quest yes so he's trying to find a way
out of Fort joy but he needs help it's
not gonna oh that's interesting so he'll
talk to you even though he already
talked to me
yeah yeah so some of our quests will be
per each player playing so even though
you have the quest he's actually trying
to just find the person who can get him
out so he's gonna ask everyone yeah he's
gonna ask both of us and whoever is able
to deliver the glove stone is gonna get
the reward but I don't know about you I
can't work and work together after
seeing the fire slugs yeah I'm not sure
that we're you know much of a position
to be off soloing these things by
ourselves so let's uh let's fight these
guys together so weird some of the other
big changes you guys have been making to
this version so the biggest change I
think of all is going to be the third
act of the game I'm not sure if you got
that far but the city of Arc's which
represents about 40 hours worth of the
game yep has been completely reworked
redone from the ground out really I'm
talking quests writing just full
gameplay experience Wow is completely
redone we had a lot of feedback from
people saying it
it-it-it was it drive a little bit it
wasn't as good as a as a payoff for the
game that came before it so we decided
to go back and improve it because we we
didn't just want to pump out like I said
before a a a port for the game we really
wanted to make the experience the best
we possibly could for you guys the fans
and yeah I think I think we've we've
really done that yeah that sounds pretty
substantial to completely change that
that whole section of the game okay
let's see here well Tenley almost a Mac
a few other things we've done is like I
said before the journals gone through a
complete overhaul I said the arena mode
is now updated and obviously a lot of
other small things for the game not
quite as extensive as an entire reworked
of Arc's but a lot of quests have just
gone through various improvements and
updates of the bug fixes and things like
that right you know be good to go and
all this is gonna be PC is gone
absolutely not only is it coming to PC
if you already own the game you'll be
getting this game showing up in your
library October or sorry August 31st
absolutely great that's awesome for yeah
we did this with the the enhanced
edition of dust one and we decided to do
it again here because it makes sense you
guys are the ones supporting us and
making the game great so we want to give
it back to you guys
okay all right so I got some oil on this
guy would be a pretty good chance for
low set of him with a the fire thing and
you actually have a fire grenade
yourself so you can be thinking a sense
about my oh I don't have enough AP
though I think you do just I think
you're you just need to press Y triangle
yeah there you go
you can't move out didn't hit either uh
when I play when we first played the
game we were playing on classic
difficulty and this was the fight that
just gave us a lot of trouble like the
combat is definitely doesn't joke around
you planned this can you plan like
classic or harder yeah we've actually
gone through and added a new difficulty
mode called story mode oh really she's
another big things of the game so if
you're really more interested in just
experiencing the story experience in
this huge RPG but you really just want
the comments to be quick and snappy
that's absolutely a new gameplay mode
for you
I love when games give just as many
options as possible for players cuz you
know yeah it's like there are some
people who just really want the
narrative and welcome characters but you
know maybe the combats just not for them
okay that's awesome that you guys are
providing that yeah we really want
everybody to field experience this huge
open story and yeah and I'm fine oh yeah
but out that's a good idea
we're doing a lot better in this one huh
we are we're definitely doing a lot
better a little bit much Oh husband I'll
tell you I think you attacked the ground
I think I think we're we're up ahead
enough in this one in fact I think you
got a good line up there for a battle
stomp those guys down yeah oh yeah oh
nice fantastic I get them like this guy
not quite enough a beer that's all right
that's okay I'll just get up close to
him for next time
all right now I'm gonna give this guy a
little battering around here nice and
I'm just gonna cook a little love tap
there okay let's let's finish these guys
off ya know she's got the pick
that's one everyone does all the hard
work and she just picks him up all right
so this is the guys that's the last guy
alive here
a little little closer there we go so
let the King touch there makes us so
that any healing done against them he's
gonna do it damage son Daniel instead
vixx is similar to undead who have a
unique mechanic in our game where if you
heal them if they take damage but if
they're poisoned
they actually heal from that so it makes
a very unique experience and that's
another thing you can do instead of
character creation is choose to play as
an undead but obviously what's gonna
happen if you go into the middle of a
crowded Town Square and take off your
mask well they're they're gonna freak
out a bit and gonna call the guards so
that I played they were we were like get
to the for joy and then immediately
everyone will just start attacking us
arise I'm attacking us and it's because
my brother was playing faint whirling
what are you okay well like you just
stand over there and maybe we'll play a
little bit and then but there's like oh
that's boring and then we figured out if
you put a bucket on his head you can
walk around and knowing who this is so
he just played the first five hours of
the game of the bucket on his head and
you guys thought it was a magical bucket
that uh it just no one notices there no
one no one seems concerned that there's
a guy with a bucket on his head
[Music]
but since we've we've managed to defeat
the crocodiles now and you've picked up
the teleportation gloves yeah we're
actually able to go back to Gao in here
and tell them about our successful deeds
let's do it sad what's the news Wow give
me my right
guess we'll follow him think so see this
quest through
[Applause]
so like I said before or and you would
alluded to before there are many ways to
escape for joy and it's not just going
under the fort and pacifier slugs it's
not just helping out go in with teleport
requests if you want and you are so bold
you can even take the Magisters head on
and the fort itself you can find one of
the other teleport routes that we've
seeded into the game or that other fans
have found you can even help out one of
the trapped elves in the in the ghetto
itself and as they will and he will help
you find a way out it's really how you
want to explore for Joe all right so I
think the first I need to equip it
[Music]
[Applause]
and their gloves right yes
so right there yes that's a
teleportation all right so now you see
that the gloves have given you a skill
or a very fun skill to play with oh
that's that's fine you got there good
teleporting I can tell for him too there
we go yeah he wants me to learn right
here he wants to teleport him on to the
ledge I just need to see you
[Music]
guys down so putting you down yeah
antenna for me that most rough across
the gulch just by the torch
and we're we've almost come to freedom
which means one story here he wants to
go right there once he's there what's he
gonna do
seems we've been duped a bit mm I think
he's gonna help us out is you good to be
true but it we got a level from that we
got some experience we learned that
sometimes people in prisons aren't in
the female colleagues I should say
that's the nicest oh well how do I get
out of here nice traps so you do have
the teleportation you do have waypoints
but there's also that little the little
tree trunk there oh it's that one looks
key revealed something there oh that a
hole well oh hey you know Danny
[Music]
where does that lead I wonder will cave
our in the dungeon yeah this might look
familiar this is actually a bit further
up from where we left off after the fire
slugs ah but thankfully it's past the
fire slug so we can avoid that comment
entirely look at that and so if we were
to do the fire slugs there we could get
to this area through another regions
mm-hmm man that's cool and unfortunate
means for me that I can't take it so I
have to go through and find my own way
of the prison well that's fine yeah
that's that's rather we have those
ability to kind of do that well yeah
this has been a pretty good look at the
game is there anything else people
should know about with the definitive
edition well it's gonna be hitting xbox
one ps4 and PC upcoming August 31st and
not only that if you've already picked
up the game on Xbox one or ps4 you can
already start playing the entire first
tactical game so while we're playing
right here right now is fully available
to you to test up and play yourself and
then once it does go live on the 31st
keep on playing with that safe it's not
invalid keep on going through and
continue your entire adventure well that
rat that is awesome cool alright well
thank you for joining me and showing off
the game just really great to have you
thank you very much for having me it's
always great to show off the game yeah I
mean you guys a little teaser I
mentioned before this is one of my
favourite games of last year and I'm
really glad that more people have a
chance to check it out and that you've
been making all these wonderful changes
for the fans that is absolutely
fantastic so yeah thanks for joining and
for all things divinity original sin to
stay tuned and GameSpot
[Music]
you
[Music]